-Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis
are competing with each other
to see who can be more extreme
on culture war nonsense
in their appeals
to the MAGA base
with DeSantis going so far
as to ban books in schools
and give out tax breaks
for gas stoves,
and Marjorie Taylor Greene
claimed at a committee
hearing that elementary schools
are spending billions of dollars
on critical race theory.
For more on this,
it's time for a closer look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A central thing
that Donald Trump revealed
about the modern
Republican Party
is they don't have
a coherent worldview or agenda.
They're completely
directionless.
They're basically Roombas
when they bump into something
they don't understand,
they just head
the opposite way.
You can see that any time
Trump opens his mouth,
he doesn't talk about
policies or issues.
He talks about manufactured
right-wing grievances
he heard about on Fox News.
Here's one example from his
recent campaign kickoff that,
as far as I can tell,
makes no sense whatsoever.
-Every day for the United States
is always April Fools'' Day.
This just occurred
to me yesterday,
because I see what's happening.
I say, "What's going on?
What's happening? What's wrong?"
It's like April Fools'', right?
We have open borders
when they should be closed.
April Fools'' Day, right?
We have prisoners and people
from mental institutions
and terrorists being dumped
into our country
when they should
not be accepted.
April Fools'', right?
We have people in the midst
of the greatest crime wave
in the history
that want to defund our police.
This is again, April Fools''.
We have Antifa and BLM
who hate our country
and burn down our cities,
and they're totally protected
by law enforcement.
And yet they put
American patriots in jail.
What's going on there?
That's all April 1st,
April 1st, April Fools'' Day.
[ Laughter ]
-I know this goes
without saying.
Those are all really bad
April Fools'' pranks.
[ Laughter ]
Every day is April Fools' Day.
Sounds like he's pitching
a sequel to "Groundhog Day".
[ Imitating Trump ] All right,
so get this --
I play a local sports anchor
who gets stranded
in a small town
called Palm Beach, Florida.
And every day I wake up
and the alarm goes off,
and the same song plays --
"Wake Me Up Before You Go-Go"
by Wham! -- so, we'll
have to pay to license that,
or if it's too expensive,
I'll just record the sound
like "Get Me Out of Bed
Before You Leave-Leave".
There you go, that part's done.
And then in the movie,
I realize it's the same day
all over again --
April Fools' Day,
April Fools' Day.
But because it's always
April Fools' Day,
I can't be sure
if it's the same day
or if it's a prank to make me
think it's the same day,
and so I learn nothing and drive
off a cliff with a groundhog.
[ Normal voice ] That's right,
every day is April Fools' Day.
And honestly, I don't know
why he's complaining,
because he's exactly
the kind of dickhead
who loves April Fools' Day.
A holiday where I lie to people
and then make fun of them
when they believe me?
I'm in!
Trump is in a competition
with his likely main rival
for the GOP nomination,
Ron DeSantis,
to appeal to the MAGA base
by throwing up
as much red meat as possible.
It's not about doing anything
to improve people's lives.
It's just about
making the libs mad.
Case in point,
you might remember that
after yet another study linked
childhood asthma to gas stoves,
there was some brief discussion
about banning gas stoves,
which the Biden administration
quickly made clear
it has no plans to do.
Now, again, the study found
that gas stoves carry roughly
the same risk of childhood
asthma as secondhand smoke.
So it's not like
switching away from gas stoves
would be the worst thing
in the world.
I mean, honestly, aside from
dirtbags who think it's cool
to light their cigarets
with them, who cares?
But Fox News lost its mind,
and then Trump and DeSantis
both followed suit.
First, Trump said this --
-We have proposed mandatory
electric stoves, think of that,
and electric cars.
They want mandatory stoves.
And people that are cooks --
I'm not much of a cook,
but the cooks are saying
gas is better.
It's crazy what they're doing.
It's crazy.
-You know, you don't need to say
I'm not much of a cook.
No one believes you've ever
cooked anything in your life
unless microwaving a 3-day-old
Filet-O-Fish
you found in your golf bag
counts as cooking.
[ Imitating Trump ] Still warm!
[ Normal voice ]
Clearly, if anyone cooks
in the Trump family,
it's Melania.
[ Laughter ]
Donald, you've barely touched
your diamonds.
For real...
[ Laughter ]
No one has ever looked
at this picture and thought,
"Well, there's a man who knows
his way around a spi--
[Laughs] around a spice rack."
I can't even imagine
what Donald Trump
cooking something
would look like.
To begin with, his skin is
so leathery and thick,
I fully believe
he could have his hand
on a hot skillet for 10 minutes
without noticing.
[ Imitating Trump ]
Is someone cooking ham?
Is -- Oh, son of a gun.
It was my hand again,
false alarm.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] So that
was Trump's reaction.
DeSantis then had to outdo him.
You see,
DeSantis's entire agenda
is just taking Fox News segments
and turning them into policies.
He staged that awful
migrant stunt
where he dropped them off
on Martha's Vineyard
without telling them
where they were going.
He moved to ban supposedly
woke books from schools,
including woke math books.
And then this week he introduced
a tax break for gas stoves.
-We just added, because I think
it needs to be done,
no tax permanently
on gas stoves.
They want your gas stove,
and we're not gonna
let that happen.
You know, this is ridiculous
that they --
and they do want to go after it.
They got blowback,
so they kind of had to back off.
They want to go
after the gas stoves.
And so we're saying, you know,
we want you to be able
to buy those free of charge
from from the state
of Florida for taxes.
-All right.
First of all, this dude
is trying so hard
to mimic Trump's hand movements.
What -- What is this thing?
What is this thing they both do
with their hands,
going out and then back in
over and over again
like they're playing
an invisible accordion?
They both look like
flightless birds
who aren't willing to give up
on the dream.
But, Ron, you're an emu.
It doesn't matter what you are,
as long as you believe.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I've never seen
anyone do this
unless they were defending
themselves
from accusation of wrongdoing
or showing up to a party
they weren't invited to.
Hey, it's me, Uncle Terry.
I know you don't want me here...
...after I stole your purse,
but I come bearing gifts
like a Marlboro Lights
and some lotto kids --
lotto tickets for the kids.
Hey, speaking of Marlboro,
you guys still got
that gas stove?
Terry no got his lighty.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Second, not only
is this silent --
[ Laughs ]
Second, not only
is this stunt dumb,
according to science, it's dumb,
according to the residents
of his own state,
because the vast majority
of stoves in Florida
are already electric --
just 8% of homes in the state
use gas stoves
and 92% choosing electric.
That's the lowest rate of
gas stove use in the country.
Oh, my God, Florida uses
electric stoves,
but that can only mean
one thing --
Florida is
[Echoes] woke.
[ Thunder rumbles ]
[ Woman cackles maniacally ]
-April Fools'.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Think about how dumb that is.
He wants a tax break
for a thing his own residents
don't use just because
it'll make the libs mad.
Also, a tax break for gas stoves
is so boring.
At least when Trump does the
culture wars, he goes all out.
[ Imitating Trump ] Antifa
is coming to your house
to take away your gas stove
and kill Santa Claus.
They want to murder --
They want to murder Santa,
'cause he's not woke.
They want to cancel Christmas
and replace it with...
-April Fools' Day.
-[ Normal voice ]
I have no idea --
I have no idea what's gonna
happen in the GOP primary,
and I've certainly
been wrong before,
but I'm just not sure
DeSantis has what it takes.
If you hire the world's
greatest scientist
to build someone in a lab
for Trump to make fun of,
you couldn't do better.
I mean, he's shorter than Trump.
He stands weird.
He's got those fancy,
little white boots.
His full name --
His full name
is Ronald Dion DeSantis.
That's 100% true.
I'm not saying DeSantis
won't win,
but Trump is gonna have
a field day with this dork.
[ Imitating Trump ]
Many people are saying
Ron Celine Dion DeSantis
likes --
wear big, white gogo boots
so he seems taller than he is.
He's a very short man,
it's very sad.
And that way he stands
with his chest
puffed out like a pigeon
who stole a French fry.
[ Normal voice ]
Trump and DeSantis,
they're just competing to see
who can win
the right-wing culture wars.
That's why DeSantis has built
his entire agenda
around culture war nonsense.
In fact, this week,
a viral video
found at least
one school library in Florida
that was basically empty because
of the DeSantis' dumb rules
against supposedly woke
subject matter in schools.
-It's a video that's been viewed
more than 5 million times.
Empty library shelves
at Mandarin Middle School
taken by a substitute teacher
who says he's at a loss
for words as the school reviews
the content of its books
following guidelines
from the state.
Schools are now required
to review their libraries
and teachers' classroom
book collections to make sure
that they don't violate
certain subject matter outlined
by the state of Florida.
-I've never heard of a library
that was simply out of books.
That sounds like an excuse
your kids would use
if you sent them to the library
to do their homework,
and they skipped it
to smoke weed at a strip mall.
And when you confronted them,
they'd probably just stand
like Ron DeSantis.
"Kevin, where are all
your books?"
"Oh, they were, uh, out?"
"The library --
The library was
all out of books?"
"Yeah?"
"Okay, I'm going to,
uh, take off."
And I do hope --
I do hope every pundit who claim
the left is responsible
for cancel culture
is losing their minds
at all the books
coming off school shelves.
Because this isn't theoretical,
it's real.
Teachers, librarians,
school districts,
they say they have no idea
what's allowed
and what's not
under DeSantis' censorship laws.
So the result is this.
This obsession
with critical race theory
has gotten so insane.
It came up at a congressional
hearing yesterday
on pandemic aide.
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
who now has been
put back on committees
by Republican leadership
after she was kicked off
by Democrats,
asked the controller general
of the United States
how much pandemic money
have been spent
on critical race theory.
Now, that's already
an absurd question,
which clearly flustered
the witness.
But pay attention
to the amount of money
she claims one school
received to promote CRT.
-Mr. Dodaro, can you tell me
how much -- how much
COVID cash went to CRT?
-CRT?
-Critical race theory
in education.
-No, I do not know that.
But I do know
that there's provisions
that the federal funds
generally are not used --
are supposed to be used
for curriculum.
-Oh.
-That's a state --
-Oh, Mr. Dodaro,
I have to tell you in Illinois
that they received $5.1 billion
at an elementary school there,
that used it
for equity and diversity.
-If that's true, which it's not,
I would think the problem
would be less CRT and more
that one elementary school
got $5.1 billion.
She really said one school
If that were true, other schools
would be so jealous.
"We had to hold a bake sale
for new soccer jerseys."
"We just financed
the last two 'Avatar' movies."
[ Laughter ]
Which, by the way,
movies which I'm guessing
Greene also thinks are real.
"The deep state doesn't want
you to know
that all those people turn blue
from the COVID vaccine,
and they're 3D now!"
So that's who the GOP thinks
should be able
to serve on committees.
Meanwhile, today,
they voted to kick
Minnesota Congresswoman
Ilhan Omar,
a refugee and one of the only
two Muslim women in the House
off the
Foreign Affairs Committee
for the simple reason
that they don't like her
or her point of view.
And by the way, that's not just
me saying that,
even Matt Gaetz,
one of the Trumpiest members
of the GOP, a guy who tried
to overturn the 2020 election
and lied about
the January 6th insurrection,
admitted as much this week.
-The reason I think
a lot of Republicans
want to kick Ilhan Omar off of
the Foreign Affairs Committee
is because they don't like
what she has to say.
-You know how [Bleep] up
something has to be
for me to agree with Matt Gaetz?
The only other thing
we see eye to eye on
are the benefits
of large foreheads.
We see eye to eye,
forehead to forehead.
Even after admitting
what was really going on here,
Gaetz still voted with
his fellow Republicans
today to remove Omar.
He didn't even have the courage
to vote no on the resolution,
even though he apparently had
the courage to wear this suit.
I mean, look at that.
Looks like a bad guy
from a futuristic videogame
called "Disco Crime 3000".
Republicans are censoring books
in schools,
removing people from committees
whose opinions they don't like,
and yet they're the ones
whining about cancel culture.
The right is fully in favor of
censorship when it suits them.
There's only one day a year
when Republicans can say
they're defenders
of free speech, and that's...
-April Fools' Day.
-This been a closer look,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]